rishi rambaran's kids were 11 9 and 5
years old when the pandemic began and
mandatory masking first came into effect
initially it was cool we got some pretty
cool masks they they liked it two years
later it's largely a non-issue still the
winnipeg dad wonders if masking is
making some things harder for his kids
you know humans we thrive on on
interaction so much of that is facial
recognition and playing off each other's
faces psychology professor michelle
morningstar says luckily humans
interpret emotions other ways children
do have access to all these other cues
that they use to infer other people's
emotions there's tone and body language
a study from late 2020 had kids look at
pictures of people either with masks on
sunglasses on or unobstructed the
results masks didn't negatively impact
ability to read emotions any more than
sunglasses did right now there are no
data to suggest that there are any
short-term or long-term harms when it
comes to masks in kids and that includes
both psychological harms and physical
harms at the hannan center in toronto
they specialize in speech and language
development our educators are masked in
an early childhood setting we're masked
out in public but they're not masked at
home so hopefully children are still
getting you know lots of good
interactions from parents at home
director janice greenberg says children
who suffer from a speech delay may be
disproportionately affected but there
are ways to foster these skills with a
mask on speak loudly stand closer to a
child and verbalize your emotion
rambaran's eldest krishana is now 14. it
bogged us a little but other than that
it was pretty
regular a sign of just how adaptable
kids can be giving experts hope any
potential impacts won't last once our
masks come off for good
jamie morocco global news toronto